[Applaus]
in den chinesischen sozialen medien
machen sie sich mut mit patriotischen
wieder website tag und dürfen die bürger
von tieren ihre wohnung nicht verlassen
die angst vor corona geht um ich liebe
china singen sie
[Musik]
pianist komplett im lockdown 13
millionen menschen die weder rein noch
raus dürfen die behörden versuchen panik
zu verhindern
wir haben genug lebensmittel auflage um
die täglichen bedürfnisse der bürger zu
befriedigen wenn du
das chinesische staatsfernsehen zeigt
massentests elf millionen in nur acht
stunden vermelden die behörden stolz in
wenigen tagen hatte es mehr als 800
infizierte gegeben das sind sehr viele
in einem land wie china das bei jedem
infizierten nervös wird und angst vor
einer belastung seines
gesundheitssystems hat
unsere ambulanzen sind immer verfügbar
wir haben einen shuttle service für
patienten der fährt sie dann ins
gartenhaus in wenigen wochen beginnen
die olympischen winterspiele in peking
der ausbruch zeigt die 0 kokot strategie
funktioniert nicht perfekt und nun gibt
es auch noch die ersten omikron fälle
das beunruhigt viele in china
peking versucht alles um die verbreitung
des virus einzudämmen
in china werden sie wohl noch eine weile
im lockdown leben müssen und
china korrespondent ulf röller
beobachtet die situation schönen guten
morgen herr oehler wie muss man sich das
vorstellen wie funktioniert das wenn
jetzt millionen menschen quasi von jetzt
auf gleich das haus nicht mehr verlassen
dürfen
also das sind dramatische und drastische
einschränkungen die wir uns
wahrscheinlich in unserem kulturkreis
gar nicht vorstellen können und die auch
gar nicht durchsetzung möglich wären wir
müssen wissen sie haben es eine stadt
von 13 millionen menschen und den hat
man von einem tag auf den anderen
komplett runter gefahren also in diese
stadt kommt weder noch jemand rein noch
kann jemand raus fahren also wer dort
vielleicht auch zu besuch war ist dort
steckengeblieben
alle müssen zu hause bleiben 30.000
menschen sind in quarantäne hotels und
die die treppe zu hause bleiben müssen
darf dann ein familienmitglied alle zwei
tage die notwendigsten lebensmittel
einkaufen mit einer frau in jinan
gesprochen die hat uns beschrieben von
ihrem fenster aus ist in einem hochhaus
sieht sie die straße die ist
menschenleer es waren auch überhaupt
keine autos es dürfen überhaupt nur
autos fahren die eingesetzt werden zur
corona bekämpfung und sie hat gesagt das
ist eine sehr angespannte atmosphäre es
wirkt fast diese riesenstadt wie eine
geisterstadt dies also komplett
heruntergefahren und wer gegen diese
corona maßnahmen gegen diese drastischen
verstößt muss mit hohen geldstrafen
rechnen also dieser virus ausbruch in
der stadt wird sehr sehr ernst genommen
zu werden immer wieder vergleiche
gebracht mit wohin wo auch eben diese
stadt innerhalb von einem tag auf den
anderen komplett runter gefahren wurde
das können sich leute hierzulande
wahrscheinlich wirklich kaum vorstellen
warum reagiert denn china wirklich so
extrem
ja auch das ist eine ganz interessante
sache weil die zahlen sind ja im
vergleich was man in europa und in
deutschland erlebt fasst ja wirklich
sehr sehr niedrig wir haben jetzt
insgesamt in etwa 810 fälle gehabt es
gab gestern nochmal 150 neue infizierte
also nichts was wirklich sehr dramatisch
ist das thema eben in china ist dass
china eine strategie fährt wo sie sagt
wir wollen gar keine infizierungen haben
und deshalb haben wir diese massiven
kontrollen der grund für diese wer sehr
strikte corona politik ist
wahrscheinlich inoffiziell dass der
mieter dass die dass die impfung die
china hat wahrscheinlich nicht von der
gleichen qualität ist wie die den europa
benutzt wird und der andere grund ist
dass eben die gesundheits struktur die
medizinische struktur in china bei
weitem nicht so gut dass wie in europa
man kann sich gar nicht solche
infektionsraten leisten wie das zum
beispiel in deutschland der fall ist das
würde zu wahnsinnigen massensterben
führen deshalb muss man sehr sehr
niedrig die infektionszahlen halten und
jeder kleiner ausbruch macht eben die
chinesischen machthaber sehr sehr nervös
noch ein ganz wichtiger punkt sie macht
es deshalb auch sehr sehr nervös weil in
wenigen wochen die olympischen
winterspielen peking stattfinden sollen
und da ist die angst groß wenn jetzt
eine welle sich aufbauen würde
china auch wenn sie nur kleines dass das
eben die spiele beeinflusst
beobachtungen und einschätzungen von
unserem korrespondenten in peking und
freyler vielen dank für das gespräch